nearly 6 000 feet up in the mountains
another mom has a huge challenge
a female black bear has spent the winter
in a high mountain cave
she needs to teach her cubs to survive
in the park
[Music]
with little to no food or water for
months
the stakes are high
but they're living in a special place
big bend is the only national park with
an entire mountain range inside its
borders
the
chisos
named for their previous inhabitants
and once home to the mescalero apache
and the comanche tribes
the mountains are a sky island oasis
40 square miles of peaks up to 8 000
feet
loom over the hot desert below
[Music]
at the height of summer
monsoon storms can dump nearly a year's
rainfall
in a few months
right now
the monsoon is a long way off
but the chisos do something incredible
[Music]
they catch the reins and store them for
year-round use
water slowly releases from deep in the
mountains
into precious spring-fed pools
[Music]
attracting critters of all types
and
all colors
[Music]
the key to survival in a desert is a
reliable source of water
[Music]
and mom knows exactly where to find it
thanks to her mom who taught her about
the hidden oases in the
chisos it's the cubs first visit to this
magical place
[Music]
every day is a school day
today's lesson is all about water
[Music]
they've never tasted or seen so much of
it
mom relaxes in the spring
but for the cubs it's playtime
[Music]
[Music]
the fun has to come to an end eventually
but mom has another lesson for her eager
students
[Music]
how to scratch that itch
[Music]
mom shows how it's done
rubbing off her winter coat and leaving
a scent behind
signaling her presence to other bears in
the park
[Music]
mom made it look easy
[Music]
but the cubs will need a lot more
practice
[Music]
for the bear family the chisos mountains
provide water and a cool refuge
but down below on the desert floor
life in the park
has more extreme challenges
[Music]
you